[Music]
my
least favorite part of leonard cone is
uh the notion that the light gets in
through the cracks
and it's reminiscent of what freud and
schopenhauer
told us about the best we could ever do
in life
for both of them the best a human being
could ever do in life
was to minimize his or her suffering
as close to zero as possible and the
essence of my remarks
is this notion that the best we can ever
do in life
is not to suffer is morally insidious
uh a political and personal
and artistic dead end and uh
here's where i'm coming from that
suffering for many of us is our lot
in life uh but
notions like that's how the light gets
in
celebrates mental suffering and this is
a serious
psychological error um
many of you who follow the arts uh have
the myth of
sylvia ploth in mind and that somehow
creativity
is a function of suffering well it turns
out we know a great deal about severe
plots
and in general what we find about
creativity
is that people who are bipolar
manic depressive as sylvia ploth was
the creativity does not occur during
depression
the creativity occurs during
hypomania on the way to mania
and in general there's quite a large
literature on the relationship
of emotional states to creativity a
hundred articles or so
and it goes strongly in the direction
that in
negative states like depression and
anxiety
we are not creative we fall back on what
we already know
in positive states
in well-being that's when we explore
that's when we're creative and
this in many ways is the essence of the
field of positive psychology
in positive psychology there are
five pillars that human beings who are
not
suffering who are not oppressed seek
positive emotion p for perma
e engagement and flow
when time stops for you are
good relationships m meaning and purpose
and a accomplishment
in the creativity literature what we
find
is by and large creativity in the arts
in the sciences in literature occurs
during perma during the positive states
and so the essence of my remarks
is uh about the notion
of where does light get in and how does
the light get in
uh depression mental illness
suffering interfere with creativity
so what's the appeal of that's how the
light gets in
through the cracks well the appeal and
the benefit
is that we believe for those of us who
suffer
for those of us who are depressives i am
one of them
we are sympathetic we console them
but there are dangers of celebrating
mental illness of celebrating pathology
first um the notion that that's how the
light gets
in true suffering is false
so creativity
in people who are suffering occurs not
because of the suffering
but in spite of the suffering
sympathizing celebrating suffering
prolonged suffering particularly for
young people
uh this myth that if you have a happy
childhood somehow
you're prevented from a life of
creativity
it prolongs suffering makes people
particularly young people
seek out suffering
in addition it discourages
people from seeking therapy and from
seeking medication for suffering
and while psychology and psychiatry are
far
from perfect we do have psychotherapies
and pharmacologies that relieve
depression
and what we have now particularly among
young people
is an epidemic of depression to our
dismay we found in
kovid unprecedented levels
in young people of anxiety and
depression
and suicide and by telling young people
somehow
that the light gets in through suffering
contributes to the epidemic it
increases the probability of depression
it increases the probability of anxiety
and it contributes to suicide now i want
to
introduce uh what mandy seligman is
about
and that mandy has been very concerned
with
uh creativity in photography
and the question is um what's the right
emotional state
for photography what encourages
creativity
in photography and mandy is the essence
of a positive psychologist
and it's my pleasure to
introduce mandy and uh to introduce
her notion of seeing happy
thank you well thank you very much for
that
yeah so as marty was talking in the
beginning
the the five pillars of
well-being um he talks about
perma p e r m a um
for a very long time um as a mom of five
i have enjoyed photography and it's been
my creative outlook um
and it really ticks all the boxes
i mean it's a joyful experience for me
it's
um it is a mindful and
flow experience for me it has created so
many wonderful relationships
and it's deeply meaningful and and
actually i think i have felt hugely
accomplished
especially uh when i turned to film
photography
um the amount of mindfulness flow
and accomplishment because it was
difficult it's uh
it every single pillar of
positive psychology was amplified
and every box ticked for me at least and
that was before covert
but then covert hit and i really found
that going out and taking photographs
really helped me to cope with
everything else that was going on in the
world it was a way of
getting out and putting my mind
somewhere else
and one of the things that i
particularly enjoyed
was as a member of the soho photo in new
york
we would have weekly lunches
where we would just bring our photos and
sit and eat lunch and we would just talk
look at each other's photos there was no
competition there was no
uh you know vying for the latest
um show or anything it was simply
a group of people that love photography
sitting around looking at photographs
um and we would help each other and we
would you know
discuss different things and give hints
and
jill and kobits this really really
increased my own personal well-being
and after a little while i started to
think about this
and i realized that it actually made a
big difference
where i pointed the camera so if i took
pictures of sad things i felt sad
but when i took pictures of happy things
it really elevated my mood i felt
so much happier um and more able to cope
i felt like
there was more possibilities
and we had all of our children at home
during kovitz so that was a very large
household
so getting supplies was difficult and
and yet if i had a good picture that
people enjoyed
you know that i felt good about this
really helped me
um anyway so part
halfway through i decided to try
something
at the gallery i you know i decided i
was going to show my happy pictures
and i was very nervous about it because
i felt that
you know photography is supposed to be
serious and so i didn't know how
my happy pictures would look so here are
a couple of photographs
those are two of my daughters that makes
me very happy
these are happy pictures i put it
together as a collection
this was in spain i love this little
girl's face
anyway i showed some of these pictures
at the gallery and
um it was there was silence and i was
anxious and nervous about this and at
the end of showing the pictures
people told me that they loved them they
loved the little moments
of connection that they saw they loved
the the real amplifying of the like oh i
love this picture
the amplifying of positive connections
look at this one so it was very
reinforcing to get people
looking at my photos and saying yeah
this is this made me feel better
so i realized that where we point the
camera is really important
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest
ideas